[Musik]
immer mehr Flüchtlinge immer mehr
Überforderungen und auch stark steigende
Gewalt auf unseren Straßen so steht es
jetzt zumindest im BKA Bericht es gibt
viel zu besprechen heute bei viertel
nach acht heute mit NZZ Journalistin und
ehemaligen SPD Oberbürgermeisterin
susanne Gaschke sie fordert eine
Verschärfung des Asylgesetzes
SPD-Politiker nasse Ahmet widerspricht
und sagt wir brauchen Zuwanderung müssen
die Menschen die zu uns kommen aber
besser integrieren bildchef Reporter
Frank Schneider sagt mit Blick auf die
aktuelle Statistik des
Bundeskriminalamts immer mehr Täter
haben ein Migrationshintergrund um das
Gewaltproblem zu lösen müssen wir auch
endlich über die Herkunft sprechen seine
Partei traf sich heute in Berlin zum
flüchtlingsgipfel CSU Politiker
Alexander Hoffmann sagt die steigende
Zahl an Flüchtlingen überfordert Städte
und Gemeinden Kanzler Scholz müsste das
jetzt zur Chefsache machen und klare
Ansagen machen
Probleme löst man nur dann wenn man
tatsächlich über die Ursachen auch
spricht dass meint auch Schauspieler Til
Schweiger der mit klaren Ansagen zur
Regierungspolitik jetzt auf die
Schlagzeile kommt er klagt an
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck Zitat
verzöpfe nur Mist richte unser Land
zugrunde sagte er und solle besser
wieder Kinderbücher schreiben die
Politiker seien so sagte Til Schweiger
nicht unsere Könige sondern unsere
Angestellten und klare Kante auch von
ihm zu den klimaklebern sie seien so
sagt er die größte Plage im Land ich
habe schon gesagt diese Schlagzeile halb
Deutschland spricht über diese
Schlagzeile und so manche werden sich
wohl auch Fragen ja woher nimmt Til
Schweiger diesen Mut und tatsächlich so
eine jetzt veröffentlichte Studie der
Uni Mannheim sagt dass inzwischen jeder
vierte Deutsche sich nicht frei fühle zu
denken zu sagen was er denkt ja nicht
bei der Arbeit nicht unter Freunden
ansonsten drohe soziale Ächtung also auf
der einen Seite Tisch jeder der kein
Blatt vor den Mund nimmt und
gleichzeitig verpassen sich immer mehr
Deutsche selbst einen Maulkorb Frau
Gaschke wer sagt was er denkt läuft der
aus ihrer Sicht tatsächlich Gefahr
sozial geächtet zu werden ich fand die
Studie ich habe die auch gesehen fand
die auch tatsächlich sehr interessant
mit den 25 Prozent das Institut für
Demoskopie Allensbach stellt schon seit
ein zwei Jahren fast 50 Prozent in deren
Umfragen fest die sagen man kann seine
Meinung nicht offen sagen ich fand das
ganz interessant wie es dort gemacht war
da waren die von den sozialen Kosten des
offenen Redens äh die Rede und das fand
ich ganz intelligent um sich selber da
einzuschätzen natürlich kann Til
Schweiger und jeder andere und wir hier
und jeder auf Twitter in Deutschland
seine Meinung sagen so viel er will
vollkommen klar niemand kommt ins
Gefängnis nicht wie in Russland also ein
freies Land ohne Demokratie in der
Hinsicht sind die Kosten gering und im
Freundeskreis das war hier auch zu
erkennen haben auch viele Leute
tatsächlich offenbar noch das Gefühl
also sie werden da verstanden selbst
wenn man unterschiedlicher Meinung ist
das hält die Freundschaft aus das geht
habe ich auch anders erlebt ehrlich
gesagt also bei hochpolarisierten
Diskussionen wie zum Beispiel in der
corona-zeit da hatte ich schon das
Gefühl dass der eine oder andere
Freundeskreis sich auch auseinander
sortiert hat relativ heftig also da war
ging es sehr an die Emotionen und dann
sozusagen auf der Arbeit am Arbeitsplatz
und ebenso in der öffentlichen sozialen
Endung da ist die Angst relativ groß und
da antworten dann auch deutlich mehr als
25%, das ist ja dann sozusagen das
Gesamtergebnis dass sie sich da Sorgen
machen und natürlich gibt es tabuisierte
Themen ich denke da wenn man eine ganze
Menge drüber zu reden haben heute es
gibt ja sozusagen also Politiker
correktness ist da immer sehr die die
ganz verkürzte Formel es gibt ja das an
sich gute Anliegen dass man also
Menschen nicht diskriminiert nicht
verletzt beim Sprechen sozusagen sie
nicht übersieht sie nicht die
thematisiert alles wunderbar hat aber zu
einer gewissen ähm wie soll ich sagen
also verächtlich und Verriegelung der
Sprache geführt also wo man nun ganz
viele Sachen gar nicht mehr unbefangen
also schon alleine Worte und Begriffe
nicht unbefangen benutzen darf also ich
meine mich mal aufgeregt hatte und zwar
schwierig hatte dass er so in einem
schultext also irgendwie das Wort mega
verwendet wurde und sie prangerte das an
und dann hatte sie dafür Ärger weil sie
es verwendet hatte obwohl sie das nur
kritisieren wollte da wird es dann irre
und das wird natürlich wahnsinnig
verstärkt ich finde man kann sich dem
ganz gut entziehen wenn man einfach
nicht auf Twitter ist aber es wird
natürlich durch die sozialen Netzwerk
politisch korrekt ist natürlich das was
Til Schweiger gesagt hat nicht Frank ist
es deine Ansicht nach dass er das tun
kann oder sich da so frei fühlt weil er
so eine Art Status einfach hat oder
glaubst es macht für ihn vielleicht noch
schwieriger am Ende vielleicht auch
schwieriger im Beruf nee das glaube ich
nicht aber ich glaube til schweige ist
so ein Typ der der so rauspolt hat und
es ist natürlich auch in der Wortwahl
natürlich ein bisschen problemisch aber
das ist so seine Art wenn man ihn kennt
und das muss man glaube ich auch hören
wenn er es in seiner unternahmlichen Art
sagt dann hat sie auch wahrscheinlich
wieder fast ein bisschen Humor trotzdem
glaube ich ist ganz ganz wichtig dass
solche Vorbilder in Anführungsstrichen
auch einfach klar sagen was sie denken
und solange man keine anderen beleidigt
oder irgendwie ja wie wir eben gehört
haben mit rassistischen oder anderen
Dingen stigmatisiert
dann sollte man ganz klar in Deutschland
seine Meinung sagen können und auch
müssen denn ich glaube das ist und da
sollten wir heute auch noch mal drüber
sprechen ganz wichtig bei bestimmten
Diskussionen wir müssen Realitäten auch
ganz klar benennen ich glaube das ist in
der Politik wenn wir heute zwei
Politiker auch hier in der Politik
heutzutage echt ein Problem man hat
immer so ein bisschen das Gefühl wenn
Realität auf Politik trifft dann ist
großes Erstaunen da wir sehen das aber
grünen Land treten die äh plötzlich ihre
Meinung ändern über Migration weil sie
plötzlich in der Realität ankommen und
sehen was bei ihnen in der Kommune los
ist welche Probleme sie haben und ich
finde das ganz ganz wichtig und da habe
ich manchmal auch das Gefühl wenn ich
diese tollen Illusion höher vom
Energiewandel den ich überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen kann wie das
funktionieren soll weil ich persönlich
komme was essen ich kenne viele bei RWE
und jetzt kann er natürlich die
Stromkonzerne sagen das funktioniert
alles nicht aber die Grundlagen im Netz
was wir da alles bräuchten für die
ganzen Dinge die wir haben wollen Autos
ähnliches wir sollten alle keine
Radiatoren zu Hause keine Heizlüfter im
Winter anschließen dann würde der
Stromnetz das nicht verkraften wir
sollen aber in ein paar Jahren mit
weniger Atomkraftwerken alle nachts
unser E-Autos
Klimaschutz er hat auch richtig auf
Robert Habeck muss man sagen eingehauen
sie als Politiker eröffnet wie sehr
überlegen Sie sich die Worte diese in
der Öffentlichkeit äußern können Sie
diese Studie nachvollziehen dass viele
sagen sie fühlen sich da nicht frei zu
sagen was sie denken ich denke man
sollte nicht verwechseln man darf nicht
seine Meinung äußern und es wird einem
widersprochen und ich habe den Eindruck
dass durch die Bubbles und Blasen in
denen man zunehmend in Social Media
Gerät dass man manchmal diesen
Realitätscheck dann nicht so wirklich
verkraftet in unserer Gesellschaft wenn
Menschen dann ganz außerhalb der Babbel
einen wieder Erden oder eine ganz andere
Meinung vertreten also ich würde mich
auch anschließen wir haben sehr geringe
politische gesellschaftliche soziale
Kosten sich zu äußern es ist eine der
freisten Demokratien der Welt in dem wir
leben und deswegen macht mich eigentlich
sehr betroffen wenn Menschen den
Eindruck haben sie dürfen ihre Meinung
nicht äußern vielleicht noch zu Tisch
weiger
ich würde ihm vielleicht den Rat geben
dass er ja vielleicht weiterhin das tun
sollte wo er seine Stärke hat und zwar
Filme drehen und Schauspieler sein denn
einige Aussagen ich habe es ja auch
gelesen und Zeitung fand ich schon auch
etwas schräg also was sie auch zitiert
hatten dass die klimakleber die größte
Plage in Deutschland sind also wir
hatten vor kurzem einen versuchten
Staatsstreich durch rechtsextreme ich
denke wenn wir wirklich eine größte
Plage im Land haben dann sind das
rechtsextreme und die Umsturz Versuche
und die Klima Kleber deren Ziele teile
ich ähm aber ich sag mal der Ansatz den
sie da wählen Menschen gegen sich auch
aufzubringen die im Berufsverkehr stehen
alleinerziehende Mütter und so weiter
das finde ich keinen guten Ansatz aber
zu sagen das ist die größte Planet finde
die Debatte führen wollen oder sie
kleiner so ein bisschen wie Schuster
bleibt bei deinen Leisten man könnte ja
auch sagen wir brauchen vielleicht mehr
Menschen die eine Debatte anstoßen die
vielleicht auch mal vor poltern und sich
trauen was zu sagen denn gerade haben
wir hier auch besprochen gerade während
der Corona heute gab es das natürlich
auch wenig ja in Twitter in Social Media
auch in ihrer Zeitung sehe ich jeden Tag
ganz viel davon deswegen wundere ich
mich dass der Eindruck entsteht man
dürfte seine Meinung nicht sagen also
ganz im Gegenteil bis hin zu
Übertretungen rassistischen Vorwürfen
rassistischen Beleidigungen wir haben
auch das N-Wort heute hier schon gehört
also man darf ja alles live und in Farbe
tausendfachen Kanälen sagen deswegen
muss sagen es ist eine Scheibe in meinen
Augen
dabei ich möchte auch hier einmal zu dem
Thema abholen in der CSU da kennt man ja
irgendwie so auch früher zumindest Franz
Josef Strauß so Haudegen die auch
wirklich mit Worten herausgepoltert
haben vielleicht mal oder irgendwie ähm
ja mit ja in der bayerischen Politik
auch mal auf dem Tisch gehauen haben hat
sich das verändert ihre Ansicht nach ist
man vorsichtiger geworden verändert weil
man natürlich merkt dass heute das
mediale Echo auf jede Aussage eine ganz
andere ist und im übrigen das jetzt was
von Kollegen gerade geäußert worden ist
das Zeig auch genau das
gesellschaftspolitische Bild das im
Moment zu problematisch ist und deswegen
hat er Til Schweiger durchaus einen
Punkt die Wahrheit ist doch die dass
wenn wir über klimakläden über
Klimaschutz reden dann ist das alles
toll dann wird alles akzeptiert und es
geht nach dem Motto der Zweck heiligt
die Mittel und wenn wir über andere
Themen reden wir haben das in der
corona-politik erlebt wenn jemand mal
eine kritische Frage gestellt hat dann
hat er sofort sagen müssen ich bin ja
kein Corona Leugner aber und ähnliches
ist beim Thema Migration da werden wir
heute noch darüber reden da ist es ja
auch so und da gibt's auch
Verantwortliche dafür die Grünen haben
schon die Agenda dass sie die Grenze des
Sagbaren verschieben und dann mancher
Stelle hat man das Gefühl es gibt nur
noch grün oder danach sie wie als CSU
auch als Union erleben das ganz deutlich
im Bundestag ich habe fast tagtäglich in
Berlin migrationspappen und bei allem
was wir dort sagen und zwar mit einer
realistischen Perspektive kommt immer
die afd-eule aber in Franz Josef Strauß
wäre doch jetzt wahrscheinlich
heutzutage in ihrer Partei auch nicht
mehr an der Spitze beispielsweise
das würde ich so nicht sagen es ist eine
andere Zeit gewesen ja genau und und die
die entscheidende Frage ist glaube ich
was wünscht sich die Öffentlichkeit von
Politikern und ich glaube dass wir heute
vor allem die Herausforderung haben dass
die Menschen bei vielen Dingen eben
nicht mehr das Vertrauen haben weil sie
selbst das Gefühl haben über bestimmte
Dinge rede ich am besten gar nicht sonst
wäre ich in irgendeine Ecke gestellt und
die die eigentlich reden sollten die die
das die Sachwalter meiner Themen sind
als Bürger die verschwurbeln dann auch
noch und versuchen wie die leistetreter
alles immer politisch korrekt zu sagen
es ist ein ewiges Ringen und politische
Korrektheit nehmen Sie Friedrich Merz
und das Thema sozialtourismus jetzt kann
man trefflich über dieses Watt streiten
das Problem war aber wir haben dann
tagelang nur noch öffentliche Debatten
zu diesem Wasser sozial Tourismus gehabt
und über das eigentliche Problem und das
eigentliche Thema hat niemand mehr
diskutiert
sie wollten reingehen ich wollte sie ja
gerade nicht ausbrennen sie wollte Herrn
Hoffmann aber sie genau ich würde nur
dafür plädieren dass du auch Til
Schweiger natürlich neben einem anderen
Mitbürger ist der seine politische
Meinung äußern darf natürlich hat er
dafür dann ein bisschen mehr Prominenz
als andere aber ich würde das eher
begrüßen wenn sich also auch Kunst und
Kultur wieder mehr einmischen würde in
die politische Debatte wird mir viel zu
viel geschwiegen und ehrlich gesagt Mama
wenn sie es tun siehe Corona kriegen sie
dann auch ganz fürchterlich auf dem Kopf
also es gibt schon eine Moralisierung
der Debatte ich glaube das kann man
nicht bestreiten und das ist eben nichts
was mit Gefängnis oder so zu tun hat
sondern mit sich unwohl fühlen ich bin
auch bei ihnen also man hat kein Recht
auf Zustimmung also wenn man was erzählt
und andere Leute finden das ganz falsch
dann können die sagen das ist ganz ganz
falsch und zwar aus folgenden Gründen
und dann kommen hoffentlich Argumente
aber wir haben so ein paar ich glaube
was sie sagen ist richtig also man muss
es vermeiden als rechtssta stigmatisiert
zu werden und rechts beendet die Debatte
sehr schnell also rechts will keiner
sein aus guten Gründen auch aus guten
historischen Gründen in Deutschland aber
man kriegt das Etikett auch schnell
verpasst auch für Sachen die ich absolut
diskussionswürdig und und fähig halten
und das sind ja manchmal ganz ihre
Themen inzwischen also vielleicht wenn
man ein bisschen ungewöhnliche Beispiele
nehmen also wir haben ein wirkliches
Doggen mal also Männer und Frauen sollen
voll erwerbstätig sein und Kinder das
ist das Beste was es für Kinder gibt ist
also möglichst viel Betreuung in
Kindergarten Schule Hort und so weiter
die Realität in der Praxis sieht
manchmal ein bisschen anders aus aber
wenn sie können garantiert ein
bürgerliches Abendessen sprengen wenn
Sie da sagen also vielleicht ist es für
die Kinder doch besser wenn die Mutter
oder von mir aus der Vater zu Hause sind
das ist also das ist gegen ein
verinnerlichtes Dortmund bisschen ist es
auch so bei dem klima-thema das ist halt
sehr stark vor die Klammer jetzt gezogen
worden ich glaube niemand bestrahlt also
wenige Leute bestreiten dass Klimawandel
ein großes Problem der Menschheit ist
aber es gibt auch eben noch ganz andere
große Probleme und das ist da kommen wir
ja drauf
genau das wollen wir jetzt mal tun über
ein Thema sprechen das viele als
Tabuthema betrachten oder zumindest
große Vorsicht haben über dieses Thema
offen zu sprechen Frank Schneider und
der Chef Reporter ist heute hier Frank
es geht um die Migrationsfrage und es
geht darum ob es ein Zusammenhang gibt
zwischen Gewalt und den neuen Zahlen die
du uns auch mitgebracht hast und der
Zuwanderung das jetzt dein Thema bei uns
ja genau bundesinnenministerin Fräser
hat ja heute die Zahlen veröffentlicht
der Kriminalitätsstatistik aus dem
letzten Jahr und da muss ich auch mal
ablesen weil es doch eine Menge Zahlen
sind sind 5,6 Millionen Straftaten 11%
mehr sogar mehr als vor Corona und 2,1
Millionen tatverdächtig das sind 10%
mehr und dann kommts 7000
783.876 davon haben keine deutsche
Staatsangehörigkeit das sind immerhin
22,6 % mehr also ein viel deutlicher
Anstieg als bei den insgesamt hat
Verdächtigen und 35% mehr Zuwanderer das
sind den absoluten Zahlen immerhin
80.000 und da muss man schon sagen das
ist ein Zusammenhang auch mit Migration
mit Zuwanderung mit Perspektivlosigkeit
für Menschen die hier hinkommen wir
haben 300.000 Menschen hier in
Deutschland die gar nicht mehr hier sein
dürfen 300.000 Menschen die eigentlich
ausgewiesen werden müssten es findet
aber nicht statt weil es dort Probleme
gibt mit personalpapieren passpapieren
mit abschiebehaftplätz mit ähnlichen
Dingen und was wir auch noch sagen
müssen das Problem mit Messern wir haben
bei den messertaten eine Zunahme von
7000 auf über 8.100 das sind 15% mehr
allein im letzten Jahr und das ist auch
ein Problem weil Messer das sagen alle
Kriminalitätsstatistiken ich habe auch
das bka-lage Papier vom letzten Jahr
mitgebracht ganz klar Messer ist ein
Statussymbol immer noch in bestimmten
zugewanderten Kulturkreisen da hat der
junge Mann ein Messer dabei das ist
seine Waffe mit der er sich verteidigen
kann seine Männlichkeit verteidigen kann
und ich glaube das ist ein riesengroßes
Problem ich will noch eins sagen zu dem
dk-lage Bild aus dem letzten Jahr da
geht es nämlich explizit und
Kriminalität im Kontext der Zuwanderung
und das sind einfach schlicht Fakten und
da ist es einfach so dass bei den
Straftaten zwischen Deutschen und
zugewanderten 40.000 500 deutsche
Staatsangehörige Opfer wurden von
Menschen die zugewandert sind und
umgekehrt nur 11.000 zugewanderte von
Deutschland also eins zu vier das
Verhältnis und noch extremer wird bei
Sexualstraftaten da wurden 2.500
deutsche Opfer
zuwanderers und nur 120 Zuwanderer Opfer
eines deutschen das ist 20 mal mehr und
da muss man einfach darüber sprechen und
ich bin seit 30 Jahren Reporter und
mache immer den Bereich innere
Sicherheit Polizei Justiz und das Thema
gruppenvergewaltigung das gab es früher
überhaupt nicht da gab es mal einzelne
Fälle wenn etwas unter Alkohol aus dem
Ruder gelaufen ist jetzt haben wir
täglich in Deutschland anhand der Zahlen
kann man das ja belegengruppen
Vergewaltigung und sehr sehr häufig
kommen die Menschen eben aus anderen
Kulturkreisen die ein anderes Frauenbild
haben dass Frauen wenn die kurze
Klamotten anhaben wenn die in die Disco
gehen sie als Freiwild betrachtet weil
ein anderes importiertes Frauenbild da
ist und ich glaube darüber muss man
reden das sind einfach Fakten das sind
jetzt einfach nur Statistiken des BKS
die ich zitiert habe und das
Bundesinnenministeriums und ich glaube
darüber muss man reden und eine Satz
noch dazu Frau Käse hat heute in ihrer
Pressekonferenz eigentlich dazu
überhaupt nichts gesagt sie hat nur
gesagt wir leben in einem sicheren Land
es gibt ein Nachholbedarf nach Corona
und die Zahlen waren vor zehn Jahren
noch schlechter und ich finde damit ist
es eben nicht getan man muss die Fakten
benennen und man muss dann auch Probleme
benennen und wir sind uns glaube ich
alle einig würden die Zahlen dann
umgekehrtes Bild ergeben das 20 Mal so
häufig deutsche Zuwanderer zu opfern
machen dann glaube ich hätten wir uns
völlig zurecht eine große Diskussion in
der Politik werden große
arbeitsrundenarbeitskreise und würden
sagen wie kriegen das Thema in den Griff
das ist Rassismus das sind schlimme
Straftaten in ist andersrum ist zuckt
man zurück und denkt nein lieber erstmal
weg moderieren und das finde ich
problematisch Frank würdest du sagen wir
haben ein Problem mit der inneren
Sicherheit ist Deutschland in deinen
Augen nicht so sicher wie
Innenministerin ca dass da steht das
glaube ich absolut das ist nicht so
sicher ist ich glaube wir leben immer
noch einen sind sehr sicheren Land aber
wir haben das natürlich wie gesagt mit
dieser Zunahme gerade auch die
Jugendkriminalität und da geht's nicht
nur um Zuwanderung man muss ja auch
sagen Tatverdächtige Kinder explodieren
Jugendliche das mag mit Corona
zusammenhängen und ich will jetzt auch
nicht wieder den Fall von Luise be in
dieser grauenhafte Tat wo das junge
Mädchen getötet wurde aber er muss schon
sagen dass auch die gewaltaffinität bei
jungen Menschen unglaublich zunimmt ganz
ab jetzt von migrationsthema auch das
ist eine riesengroße Baustelle und wir
sehen ja auch diese gewaltaffinität bei
tiktok zum Beispiel tiktok sein
Riesenproblem Social Media insgesamt
sein Riesenproblem junge Leute haben
sich abgekoppelt die haben 8:15 Uhr
nicht mehr im Kopf wie wir und 20 Uhr
die Tagesschau die gucken keine normalen
Nachrichten die sind nur in ihrer Blase
und die sind nur noch da unterwegs wo
sie die Dinge finden die Sie suchen und
die Aufmerksamkeitsdefizite sind das so
stark dass die bei einem Video nach
einer Sekunde Weg zwei wie so schön
heißt wenn sie nicht interessiert und
deswegen müssen die Videos umso brutaler
sein der neueste Trend ist gerade die
französische Narbe dann kneift sich oder
einen anderen so lange ins Gesicht bis
eine eine blutige Wunde hinterher zurück
bleibt oder ein ein wir sind ein
Knutschfleck am besten mit Narbe und das
präsentiert man dann stolz also das
zeigt wo man da unterwegs ist auch mit
eigenverletzung und ich glaube das sind
riesen Probleme und das so weg
moderieren wir leben in einem sicheren
Land ja diese Probleme
nennen und dass man auch mehr Übungen
Herkunft der Täter spricht vor
gasgranisiert den Eindruck dass wir zu
wenig über die Herkunft der Täter
sprechen ja also jedenfalls sehr sehr
vorsichtig es gibt dann ja auch immer
die Einwände die auch berechtigt sind da
sind dann wahrscheinlich wieder die die
berühmten Verstöße gegen das
Ausländerrecht auch mit drin und so
weiter okay dann nehme ich dann nämlich
das zurück also ja klar weil der
Rassismus Vorwurf natürlich immer um die
Ecke dauert und es gibt ja auch
Rassisten und sehr sehr unfreundliche
Menschen in unserem Land das ist ja gar
keine Frage nur damit kriegt man das
Problem nicht weg und ich bin genau Ihre
Meinung wir müssen es benennen und sagen
und was können wir denn jetzt tun denn
das ist ja das ist ja tatsächlich also
das genau das Problem so lange wir nicht
mal drüber reden können werden uns keine
Strategien einfallen und es gibt ja noch
andere Tabus also ich habe mir natürlich
auch genau besonders das mit den Kindern
sehr angeschaut weil ich mich eben seit
vielen Jahren auch mit diesem ganzen
Problem also von von Erziehungsfragen
und und auch eben Kinder Jugendliche und
so beschäftigen immer fragt sich
natürlich woher es kommt und ich glaube
dass ihre Analyse da auch vollkommen
richtig ist das betrifft alle also die
und das muss man da muss man auch ein
Tabu wenn man Eltern sagt ihr führt es
herbei also wenn ihr euren Kindern so
viel bildschirmzeit einräumt wenn ihr
sie so alleine lasst also mit dem Handy
wenn ihr sie so wenig also in unsere
anderen Kulturtechniken einführt und
auch dazu anhaltet und ihnen auch
beibringt was daran gut ist dann ist das
kein Wunder was jetzt passiert ist ist
schon Desaster damit Ansage dazu und
wenn man jetzt sieht dass die Diskussion
nach Hamburg mit der mit der Schusswaffe
die natürlich ganz schlimm war der Mann
hat die legal erworben und hatte dann
offenbar einen einen persönliches
Problem mit dieser Gemeinde ein
grauenhafter Amoklauf aber schwierig zu
verhindern obwohl es vorher ein Hinweis
gab weil er nur mal legal eine Waffe
besessen hat darüber wird sehr viel
diskutiert müssen das Waffengesetz
verschärfen darüber kann man ja auch
diskutieren darüber wird gesprochen aber
gleichzeitig nach Luise war das Problem
nach dem Mord an diesem zwölfjährigen
Mädchen ähm ja aus jugendschutzgrün
dürfen in der zu nicht sagen auch nicht
zu den Tätern es war so ein bisschen
gehen Sie weiter es gibt nicht zu sehen
wir gehen über zur Tagesordnung und ich
glaube klar muss man auch die Täterinnen
schützen denn am Ende müssen sind es
auch Opfer wer macht sowas in dem Alter
aber wenn man heute weiß die haben sich
im Internet schlau gemacht dass sie
genau gesehen haben wir sind straf
unmündig uns droht nicht sie haben hat
geplant dann muss man dem ins Auge
schauen und wir wissen alle auch gerade
in den nach corona-zeit ist der einzige
Punkt für Frau Feser da gab es in
Jugend- und kinderpsychiatrien halt
Wartelisten von bis zu einem Jahr und
ich glaube da kommt noch etwas in der
Aufarbeitung auf uns zu was wir
unbedingt ernst nehmen müssen ach mit
wir alle wollen keine Gewalt wie würden
sie das angehen mehr Transparenz das ist
natürlich nicht nur eine Frage der
Herkunft sondern der auch eine soziale
Frage ob arm ob reich ob integriert ob
nicht integriert wie sind sie das angeht
ich denke Probleme angehen sie haben
einige angesprochen auch sie ich kann
mich da einfach nur anschließen es
bringt aber nichts den Menschen Angst zu
machen ich habe in Nürnberg eine der
sichersten Großstädte in einem der
sichersten freistaate in einer der
sichersten Länder der Welt Menschen die
sich von Frauen die sich nachts nicht
trauen von der Straßenbahn noch nach
Hause zu laufen die sich abholen lassen
von ihrem Freund
wenn man sich dann aber anschaut wie
sicher ist eigentlich ist wie wenig
tatsächlich auf den Straßen passiert und
wenn man sich dann anschaut wo
sexualisierte gew am meisten vorkommt
und zwar im privaten Bereich also das
heißt nicht vom fremden irgendwo im
Dunkeln sondern im daheim dort wo man
regelmäßig hingeht arbeitsplatzverein
oder ähnliches dann dann muss man da
tatsächlich besser und näher hinschauen
wir wissen jeden dritten Tag stirbt eine
Frau durch die Hand ihres Ex Partners
oder Partners femizide sind ein Problem
darüber wird auch sehr wenig gesprochen
und dann ist es mir halt ein bisschen zu
wenig tatsächlich
einfach nur die Schlagzeile zu machen
wie importieren Gewalt sondern Gewalt
gibt es
tatsächlich auch vor allem im Privaten
Nahbereich wenn es um sexualisierte
Gewalt geht und da ist die Frage was
macht man da dagegen und da geht bei uns
die Zahlen des BKA die Frank Schneider
gerade hier vorgetragen hat nicht also
mich beunruhigt das zu wenig darüber
gesprochen wird dass wir in Bayern
beispielsweise keine dauerhafte oder
keine flächendeckende Förderung von
Frauenhäusern haben Frauen Notrufnummern
usw
eine reine Stellvertreter Debatte weil
sie genau über dieses Thema nach meiner
Wahrnehmung gerade bewusst nicht reden
wollen das ich komme
um andere über eine Meinung aber über
dieses Thema wie ist der Herr Schneide
gerade zitiert da wollen sie gerade
ausdrücklich nicht reden ich spreche
darüber ich spreche darüber aber lassen
Sie mich diesen Punkt noch machen ich
glaube dass wir da auch genauer
hinschauen müssen beim Thema
Ausländerin und Ausländer muss man ganz
ehrlich ganz klar sagen jeder der die
PKS in den letzten Jahren angeschaut hat
sieht das Ausländer nicht kriminelle
sind als Biodeutsche sage ich jetzt mal
und deswegen finde ich deswegen finde
ich bei diesen Zuwachszahlen wirklich
nicht also tatsächlich wenn sie sich das
nur die letzten Jahre und Jahrzehnte
anschauen dann müssten sie eigentlich
als jemand der sich damit selber ausgeht
über alle Bereiche ich kann sie beraten
nur für das Ausländer nicht krimineller
sind noch alles für die Bäcker ist des
letzten Jahres noch mal Zunahme
insgesamt bei Tatverdächtigen zehn
Prozent bei nicht in Deutsch über die
Zunahme dann ist es jetzt eine neue
Situation und man muss noch mal schauen
also da ist einmal einigen dass wir
genau über diese Leute sprechen
immer wieder und regelmäßig und auch vor
dieser PKS würde immer wieder der
Eindruck Ausländer sein krimineller als
deutsche und das stimmt erstmal nicht da
geben Sie mir recht nee da gebe ich
genau das mitgebracht habe aus Berlin
aus dem Jahre 2004 bis 2006 da hat
dieser Senat in Berlin ich wollte mich
mal zeigen dass sie mich immer nichts
passiert es wird immer Schweden Studien
in Auftrag gegeben was passiert nichts
was vor 20 Jahren reden jetzt oder knapp
20 Jahren da ging es darum um die
massive Zunahme von Gewalt von
Jugendlichen nicht Deutscher und mit
Migrationshintergrund das nannte sich
damals auch Krim den Kontext der
Zuwanderung und Migration und da war es
in Berlin schon so dass zwischen 204 und
2006 nicht deutsche Jugendliche viermal
so häufig registriert wurden bei
Raubdelikten fünfmal so häufig bei
Körperverletzungsdelikten dreimal so
häufig bei
Gewalt auf Straßen und Wegen heißt das
dreimal so häufig bei sexualelegten 7,5
Mal so häufig bei Vergewaltigung und das
muss man auch noch sagen dass der Anteil
männlicher nicht deutscher tatverlegt
deren bestimmten Direktion in Berlin und
in der nenne ich jetzt nur mal die
Direktion 5 das ist Neukölln Friedrich
sein bei 81% lag und ich will nur ganz
kurz sagen und da wurde ein Arbeitskreis
gebildet bis 2011 dann wechselte der
Senat passiert ist dann nach meiner
Recherche überhaupt nicht und man muss
sagen von Intensivtätern 319 gibt es 165
nicht deutsche und von den Deutschen die
darin noch mal die Hälfte mit
Migrationshintergrund und das sind
Fakten die man benennen muss ich komme
aus der Stadt Essen da gibt's auch
intensiv Täter die erfasst werden um die
man sich besonders kümmert und das ist
eben auch so dass der Anteil der
wirklich rein deutschen dort bei einem
zu niedrigen einstelligen Prozentzahl
liegt zu sagen das hat nur also sind
nicht nur Menschen die frisch nach
Deutschland gekommen sind manchmal auch
die zweite dritte Generation da
verzweifeln noch Eltern wenn man zum
Beispiel in Duisburg Marxloh mit Türken
spricht die dort lange leben die sind
verzweifelt weil ihnen die jungen Leute
Wegrutschen und ich glaube das ist eben
genau das Problem man sagt mir das ist
gar nicht so das sind alles nur nackte
Zahlen und Fakten für jeden ersichtlich
aber das Problem ist in die Falle ist
Frau Feser heute insofern auch wieder
getappt man spricht es weiter nicht an
weil man glaubt man kann es dann weg
moderieren na gut aber wir sitzen jetzt
hier beispielsweise hier bei ihnen sie
sprechen es ja an und ich will ihn nur
noch mal ich will noch mal festhalten
also sie haben jetzt wieder einzelne
Gruppen herausgezogen und einzelne
Tatbestände und da kann man festhalten
es gibt in bestimmten Bereichen
vielleicht Probleme aber große Mode über
alle Bereiche hinweg gesehen sind
Ausländer nicht krimineller als deutsche
suchen erstmal festhalten und dann kann
man sich um die Probleme kümmern aber
das sind jetzt wieder mit der Pinzette
unterwegs ich würde Ihnen an einer
Stelle bei Pflichten und sagen und man
sollte nicht diesen verallgemeinern
sagen dass man sagt migration
folgt Straftaten das kann man so nicht
sagen aber selbst wollte aber
selbstkritisch als Politik müssen wir
sagen falsche Migrationspolitik erzeugt
Straftaten weil sonst haben wir
tatsächlich groteske Gegebenheiten
denken Sie an die Silvesternacht in
Berlin ganz Deutschland hat gesehen was
man dort über TV an an dem Abend zu
sehen hatte nämlich Leute die in
geöffnetem Sanitätswagen Pflastersteine
reingeworfen haben und es war
augenscheinlich ein hoher Anteil ein
überproportional hoher Anteil an Leuten
mit Migrationshintergrund und
stattdessen gab es eine riesige Debatte
wo dann Entschuldigung vor allem
Vertreter der Ampel der Öffentlichkeit
versucht haben zu erklären was sie da
jetzt gefälligst zu sehen haben wir
hatten ein ähnliches Ereignis das war
die Silvester nach
2015/2016 2016 in Köln da war das
Problem genau das was sie sehr schön
besprochen haben nämlich das Frauenbild
des da manche mit in dieses Land bringen
und da müssen wir irgendwann mal das
Signal setzen und sagen jawohl das
wollen wir nicht da hat im übrigen die
Politik gehandelt ich weiß nicht ob sie
das mitbekommen haben weil es hat damals
einen neuen Straftatbestand gegeben
Übergriffe aus Gruppen weil ganz wenige
dieser Taten abgeurteilt werden konnten
ich habe damals mit Opfern reden dürfen
ganz traumatisch für die jungen Frauen
und das Hauptproblem war auch für den
Rechtsstaat das ist kaum Urteile gab
weil man musste ja detailliert
nachweisen welche Hand von wem kam und
wer welchen Tag Beitrag geleistet hat
und da ist es dann schon so dass die
Leute das auch wahrnehmen und dann auch
wieder Vertrauen in die Politik gewinnen
aber wenn wir ich sage jetzt mal immer
so tun als gäbe es diese Dinge nicht
glaube ich dass wir im Laufe der Zeit
mehr und mehr den
gesellschaftspolitischen Konsens in
Sachen Migration in unserem Land aufs
Spiel setzen das heißt wir erzeugen
eigentlich genau das Gegenteil von dem
was wir wollen
kommen lassen ich würde vor allem auch
gerne über die Ursachen reden weil jetzt
haben wir Beispiele und zahlen und ich
möchte einmal an den Kern glauben Sie
dass man auch sagen kann dass wir uns in
der Integration zu wenig kümmern dass
viele Menschen zu sehr alleine gelassen
werden ich würde sogar dem Herrn
Kollegen Hoffmann Recht geben in einem
Satz und zwar das eine falsche
Integrationspolitik oder falsche
Migrationspolitik haben sie jetzt gesagt
führt vielleicht zu Gewalt und da gebe
ich Ihnen schon recht aber ich glaube da
ziehen wir jetzt unterschiedliche
Schlüssel draus also mein Schlüssel ist
mein Schluss ist dass wir viel zu lange
und da waren die Konservativen im Land
auch dafür verantwortlich dass wir viel
zu lange Menschen wenig
Angebote gegeben haben sich zu
integrieren am Arbeitsmarkt teilhaben zu
können und ich glaube das gefährlichste
was man machen kann ist doch jungen
Menschen keine Perspektive zu geben zu
sagen okay du bist jetzt hier seit fünf
sechs ich hatte kürzlich jemanden in
Nürnberg bei einer Podiumsdiskussion der
hat mich bekniedert gemeint er Ahmet ich
bin seit acht Jahren hier in Deutschland
und ich darf nicht arbeiten und am
besten dann wie lange Zeiten auch noch
in irgendwelchen Unterkünften zusammen
gefährlich ist jetzt mal dass das
natürlich kein positiver ausgangspunkt
ist für eine friedliche Gesellschaft das
sehe ich und deswegen haben wir als SPD
immer darauf gesetzt wir wollen Menschen
Chancen geben wenn sie länger hier sind
wir wollen ihn bleibeperspektiven geben
und denjenigen die fair sind und auch
ihre Identität aufklären und mitspielen
und sich integriert haben den wollen wir
Chancen geben in dem Berufsleben
durchzustarten aber wenn sie dann schon
die Grenze oder den Unterschied zu den
konservativen aufzeigen dann will ich
sie schon mal darauf hinweisen dass die
Kriminalitätszahlen in Bayern die
niedrigsten sind seit e und je eine
csu-staatsregierung und in München haben
wir einen höheren Migrationsanteil als
in Berlin und trotzdem haben wir solche
Bilder eben nicht von der Silvesternacht
dass er gibt es einen signifikanten
Unterschied und ich weigere mich immer
bei dieser völlig selbstkritischen
Betrachtung sondern nach dem Motto ach
das haben wir jetzt alle selbst zu
verantworten auch als Politiker man muss
sich das mal überlegen wir reden immer
über Integration und wenn jemand in
einen offenen äh Rettungswagen auf
Ehrenamtliche in einer Silvesternacht
Pflastersteine schmeißt dann stellt er
oder er weiß und zwar in beeindruckender
Art und Weise
wir hatten beispielsweise hier den
Bürgermeister von der Schönau am
Königssee und dort in Bayern wenn auch
150 Flüchtlinge vorwiegend Männer in
eine ferienwohnheim gebracht und das in
der Sendung halt gesagt ich werde völlig
im Stich gelassen auch von der
bayerischen Politik der Kurs ist auch
fatal aber das Problem ist doch ein
anderes das Problem ist doch das dass
wir eine Ampel erleben die eine Politik
der offenen Türen macht und ich trete
sehr dafür ein dass wir mit den Menschen
die zu uns kommen weil sie halt jetzt
mal da sind selbstverständlich anständig
umgehen aber uns muss doch allen klar
sein dass dieser Kurs so nicht
weitergehen wir müssen die Türen zu
machen Brüssel hat recht wenn sie
mittlerweile darüber nachdenken Zäune zu
errichten weil wir mal diese ganze
Geschichte kann ich noch gerne mehr dazu
sagen denken müssen nicht nur bis ins
Mittelmeer sondern wir müssen die
Geschichte denken bis in die Sache ja da
kommen wir also wir kommen auch noch auf
die europäische Ebene vorher möchte ich
aber zu ihrem Thema kommen ja auch mit
den sie sind auch hier und Sie sagen wir
werden gut regiert und wir brauchen
Zuwanderung und zwar die richtige und
dass ihr Thema ja also meine These ist
dass die Ampel dafür sorgt dass wir
gerade in ganz ganz schwierigen Zeiten
Deutschland bezahlbar halten das ist
Leben bezahlbar bleibt ich denke Olaf
Scholz und diese neue Bundesregierung
sind ein Glücksfall für Deutschland
Deutschland wir haben in ganz
schwierigen Zeiten hohe Inflation
Entlastungen für Menschen geschafft wir
haben ein Gaspreis der sich verdreifacht
hat und nach der gaspreisbremse werden
am Ende des Jahres wird eine vierköpfige
Familie beispielsweise nicht mehr zahlen
als vorher das heißt sparen sich sehr
sehr viel Geld wir haben eine
strompreisbremse wo eine vierköpfige
Familie im Monat 30 € sich sparen wird
wir haben jetzt den gordischen Knoten
beim deutschland-ticket Durchstoßen wir
können mit 49 € allen Pendlerinnen und
Pendlern ein super Angebot machen
übrigens nicht nur in den Städten
sondern auch auf dem Land ich habe da
ein Beispiel mal mitgebracht wenn man
täglich pendelt von Landshut nach
München ähm dann zahlt man heute 289
Euro und das wird danach auf 49 €
zurückgehen und das heißt es ist eine
unglaubliche Ersparnis und es heißt auch
diese Ampel modernisiert das Land denn
es geht nicht einfach nur Entlastungen
sondern wir setzen auch Anreize dafür
dass Menschen umsteigen dass sie
wirklich den öffentlichen Nahverkehr
stärken
und beim Thema Modernisierung
Energiewende beispielsweise jetzt
kürzlich aus dem Koalitionsausschuss ja
wir wollen das neue Heizungen zu 65% aus
Erneuerbaren gespeist werden aber es
soll sich auch jeder leisten können also
ich sag mal große Entlastungen in großen
Zeiten der Krise und gleichzeitig
Modernisierung die Ampel ist gut für
Deutschland
ein sehr schönes soziale demokratisches
Statement denn ich bin ja auch sozial
danke Spaß mal ich kenne mich auch noch
immer so ein bisschen damit aus und es
ist ja auch es ist ja auch richtig das
sind ganz viele Wohltaten eins der
Probleme dabei ist dass sie die
Staatsverschuldung in wahnsinnige Höhen
treiben inzwischen das hat auch schon
unter der großen Koalition angefangen
das jetzt nicht nur Schuld der Ampel
aber das kriegt natürlich ein
wahnsinnigerweise zur Inflation bei und
das wiederum macht es Menschen dann sehr
viel schwerer also nicht es ist schon
eine tote Spirale und sozusagen
daran ist ja der Bundeskanzler der
absolute sozusagen großkönner und
Großmeister also sozusagen von der
eigenen Arbeit gut zu reden also jetzt
nach diesen diesen sehr sehr langen
Koalitionstreffen waren wir schon bei
drei sehr also sehr sehr sehr gute
Ergebnisse haben wir immer und es ist
immer alles ganz hervorragend und damit
passt nicht so ganz zusammen also ich
will das gar nicht in Abrede stellen was
sie was sie positiv getan haben es geht
mal wieder nicht sehr mit der SPD nach
Hause auch ein Problem würde dass die
SPD mal nachdenken müsste und das
Vertrauen in Holz in die demokratischen
Institutionen und gerade in die
koalitions tragenden Parteien ist
katastrophal niedrig das ist ganz
dramatisch gefallen in den ersten 15
Monaten ihrer Regierungszeit und da
müssten da finde ich würde ich mich
selber doch wenn ich daran beteiligt
wäre an dieser Währung einfach mal
fragen woran liegt das also sind die
Leute alle zu blöd zu verstehen was wir
für tolle Wohltaten für sie machen oder
gibt's doch sozusagen eigentlich andere
Bedürfnisse oder andere
Prioritätensetzung ich habe vorhin schon
mal gesagt sie haben sehr stark und dann
ich kenne auch die Grünen ganz gut
sozusagen auch aus eigenen politischen
erleben die haben den höchsten nerfaktor
in der politischen Konstellation das
heißt die setzen sich weil die haben
auch die Moral auf ihrer Seite die haben
wir einfach Recht und man ist dann
geneigt da sehr viel nachzugeben und
insofern ist das Klima sehr stark vor
der Klammer und ich glaube also dass die
Menschen in diesem Land ganz stark
wahrnehmen dass das eine wichtige Frage
ist aber das ist andere gibt die ganz
ganz schlimm brach liegen und Sie haben
ja recht ist als ein schönes günstiges
Ticket wenn dann überhaupt mal ein Zug
fährt und wenn er pünktlich fährt und
wenn er nicht ausfällt eine Kollegin von
mir sitzt gerade seit acht Stunden mit
ihrer Tochter in der Notaufnahme die hat
über 40 Fieber und starke Magenschmerzen
und es hat keiner Zeit sich das
anzusehen also wir haben eine riesiges
Problem im Gesundheits- und
Pflegebereich wir haben dysfunktionale
Schulen wo also Kinder mit
Migrationshintergrund und Deutsch
ständige Kinder alle also zum großen
Anteilen rauskommen
rechnen können nicht wir haben also im
Grunde Verdi braucht gar nicht mehr groß
zu streiten um den Verkehrskollaps dabei
zu führen also wir haben fundamentale
Probleme in diesem Land und man hat das
Gefühl okay die Ampel adressiert also
mit großen jetzt sozusagen diese eine
Frage
sozusagen deren Eintreten also der der
prognostizierten Katastrophe immer noch
nur eine Katastrophe ist und in der
Zukunft liegt aber wir haben sehr viel
Elend und sehr viele Probleme im Hier
und Jetzt die Leute haben das Gefühl ihr
Land funktioniert irgendwie nicht mehr
und also ich weiß nicht wenn ich der
Kanzler wäre und ich hätte seine
Beliebtheit und zutrauenswerte und diese
Probleme würde ich mich mal fragen ob
ich was anderes adressieren muss zu
wenig kritisch mit sich ins Gericht
vielleicht zumindest auch hinter den
Kulissen vielleicht finden die Gespräche
die Frau Gaschke sich hier wünscht
zumindest in der Koalition oder in der
parteilichstadt ja also ich denke wir
haben ein ganzes Bündel an Problemen wir
hatten die Pandemie zu Beginn dieser
Regierungszeit sehr sehr gegenwärtig wir
haben jetzt diesen eroberungs und
Angriffskrieg vom Putin wir haben die
damit zusammenhängende Energiekrise wir
haben die Inflation und diese Regierung
hat auf all diese Fragen Antworten
gegeben
das ist ja wirklich der der der
Inbegriff Fehlen der Selbstkritik wenn
Sie den Satz sagen die Ampel ist gut für
unser Land dann muss ich kurz innehalten
und überlege ob das real Satire sein
soll das ist so ähnlich wie wenn wir die
bundestagskanzler bei der bei der
Regierungserklärung zuhören und ich
stelle mir die Frage in welchem Land ist
dieser Mann eigentlich Bundeskanzler
aber und sowas lassen sich das ausführen
und und genauso ist es jetzt bei dem
Koalitionsgipfel passiert da schaut ein
ganzes Land zu und ein ganzes Land weiß
was die akuten Fragen unserer Zeit sind
die Frau gaschka hat sehr schön
skizziert und dann kommt eigentlich
überhaupt nicht raus ich will nur mal
ein paar Beispiele nennen wir haben im
Moment immer noch die Frage die die
Konstellation dass die Leute auf die
Entlastung bei Heizöl warten und auf die
Entlastung bei Pellets ist nichts
passiert ich habe in meinem Wahlkreis
habe ich mittlerweile ambulante
Pflegedienste die müssen Insolvenz
anmelden weil die Pflege des Pflegegeld
nicht angestiegen ist obwohl das
Lauterbach seit 12 Monaten immer wieder
vollmundig ankündigt und die haben
keinen Inflationsausgleich bekommen die
haben nichts bekommen um die höheren
Spritpreise abzubilden da gibt es bis
heute keine Lösung ich dachte eigentlich
dass sowas in den Koalitionsgipfel
besprochen wird der ganze
Haushaltsstreit ist noch überhaupt nicht
beigelegt das wird wieder aufploppen wir
kriegen das über den Flurfunk mit das
Christian Lindner auf dem Geld sitzt was
heißt auf einem Geld sitzt er sagt
richtigerweise wir haben kein Geld mehr
und wir haben für diese Wohltaten wie
sie versprecht haben wir das Geld nicht
und um die Energiepreise mal in den
Fokus zu nehmen wir hatten Glück mit
einem milden Winter und jetzt läuft die
Ampel durch die Gegend und sagt wir
haben die richtigen Maßnahmen
eingeleitet die Geschichte war doch
anders der der energiepreismarkt war ein
fesselt und da war vor allem mal eine
Person verantwortlich das war Robert
habe ich weil wenn ich nämlich dann im
Februar März durch die Gegend lauft und
erklärt uns geht uns geht das Gas aus
und die Leute können nicht mehr heizen
und die Firmen kriegen auch keine
Energie mehr und vielleicht haben wir
Blackouts davon hat er schon im März
abonniert dann muss ich mich nicht
wundern dass ab März die Preise nach
oben gegangen sind wir haben eine
Vervierfachung der Pelletspreise weil
große Unternehmen die sich leisten
konnten gesagt im oh der Habeck hat
Angst dass wir keine Pellets mehr haben
da haben die auf dem Markt eingekauft
wie verrückt ich habe jetzt letzte Woche
ein großes Unternehmen einer der größten
Arbeitgeber in meinem Wahlkreis 471
Arbeitsplätze
Automobilzulieferer die kündigen jetzt
an dass sie 2025 zu machen und sie sagen
die Ampel ist ein Glücksfall für
Deutschland wenn ich das den Leuten dort
sage werde ich mit Gegenständen bewerfen
das ist sehr spannend weil ich Ihnen
mitteilen kann dass als ich gerade aus
Bayern hierher kam ich die Meldung
gesehen habe dass sogar Herr Söder
inzwischen dieser Meinung ist dass die
Ampel gut für Deutschland
tatsächlich heute am Hauptbahnhof in
Münchenstein
gemacht super dass Deutschland Ticket
kommt und er will dass es sogar noch
über 2025 hinaus geht also das ist ja
immer ein anderes Thema gewesen als ihr
neun Euro Ticket und ich habe was
anderes diskutieren
können und das machen wir auch gleich
wieder bei einer kurz nach einer kurzen
Pause hier bei 8:15 Uhr freue mich sehr
wenn Sie bei uns bleiben bis gleich
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herrenanzug für 8:15 Uhr wir haben viel
Gesprächsstoff muss das wirklich sein
das ist doch völlig Realität ich finde
diese Debatten unheimlich wichtig
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht ruinieren
ich sag ehrlich gesagt ist das fast
totalitär was sie davon
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glückler
und Herr Bruder sich optisch ein
bisschen angepasst das Problem ist nicht
dass wir zu wenig Stadt haben wir haben
zu viel Staaten wenn die alle wegfallen
und wir uns gegenseitig in Berlin Mitte
Cappuccinos verkaufen das funktioniert
nicht dann ist mit Wohlstand oder ist
alles essen als freiheitsliebender
Mensch würde ich sagen das muss jedem
erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und Umgebungen von
Menschen in unserem Land fordert dann
müsst ihr bei euch anfangen
ich finde aber diese gesamte Debatte die
wir auch fühlen auch ein bisschen
verrückt das ist nicht aufgearbeitet und
das müssen wir noch machen und das ist
leider Gottes auch ein Punkt mit dem
Gerät
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zurück hier bei
viertel nach acht in einer Runde die
heftig diskutiert wir sind uns hier
nicht immer einer Meinung und genau so
wollen wir weitermachen und einander
zuhören es geht um das Thema Zuwanderung
Alexander Hoffmann von der CSU ist hier
und sagt ja gerne aber qualifizierte
Fachkräfte das ist ihr Thema genau der
Punkt ist doch wir brauchen echte
Fachkräfte und meine These ist dass uns
vor allem die Ampel mit einer völlig
absurden Zuwanderungspolitik
konfrontiert im Moment das wird immer
über Fachkräfte zuwanderungskonzeption
wird es dann immer verkauft und
letztendlich ist es nichts anderes als
eine Politik der offenen Türen die eine
ganz gefährliche Konsequenz in jeder
Hinsicht hat erstens ins
gefährlich die sich besser nicht auf dem
Weg machen sollten wir erleben das
Sterben im Mittelmeer das viel größere
Grab in der Region ist die Sahara und
die ist richtige Signal wäre eigentlich
in alle Teile Afrikas du brauchst dich
nicht auf dem Weg zu machen weil du nach
Europa nicht reinkommst die Ampel ist
Geisterfahrer in Europa alle
europäischen Länder fahren mittlerweile
eine sehr restriktiven asylkurs auch
eine sehr restriktiven zuwanderungskurs
und die Ampel scherrt dort aus was im
übrigen auch zu Irritation bei unseren
bei unseren europäischen Nachbarn führt
und was das Thema Fachkräfte Zuwanderung
an geht da kriegen wir dann immer auch
von Heil erzählt ja und wir brauchen
Fachkräfte und wir haben jetzt genau die
optimale Variante damit ihr alle zukommt
zu uns kommen das Problem ist aber das
alles in einen Topf geworfen wird die
Fachkraft die Arbeitskraft und dann
gibt's am Schluss auch noch den
Spurwechsel von Asyl rüber in den ganz
normalen Arbeitsmarkt und das ist
brandgefährlich wird dann am Schluss
noch garniert immer mit dem Vergleich zu
Kanada mit dem Punktesystem kann das man
kann Kanada und das deutsche
zuwanderungssystem nicht einmal im
Ansatz vergleichen und der signifikant
ist der Unterschied ist dass in Kanada
ein Großteil derer die vor der Tür
stehen wirklich arbeitswillige und
Großteil Fachkräfte sind und wir haben
bei uns nach wie vor zu viele Menschen
die Sicherheit wollen die aber auch
soziale Sicherheit wollen und die sich
am Ende eben nicht in unseren
Arbeitsmarkt einbringen
heute zum flüchtlingsgipfel der
Unionsparteien geladen glauben sie dass
da auch Thema ist wie man Fachkräfte
nach Deutschland bekommt wie man
qualifizierte Fachkräfte bekommt also
bei dem Gipfel denke ich wird vor allem
mal Thema sein es gibt ein offenes
Mikrofon das mal die Oberbürgermeister
und die Landräte schildern können dass
einfach das Wasser mittlerweile
Oberkante Unterlippe steht es gibt keine
Unterkünfte mehr keinerlei Möglichkeiten
mehr die Menschen unterzubringen wir
hatten vorhin das Beispiel dass das
natürlich dann in einem kleinen Ort auf
Widerstand trifft wenn der 150
Flüchtlinge auf 400 Einwohner stoßen das
ist eine
untragbare Unterbringungssituation wir
haben keine Plätze in den Kitas keine
Plätze in den Schulen und ich glaube das
heute vor allem mal die
Oberbürgermeister und Landräte ihrem
Ärger Luft machen werden weil sie völlig
allein gelassen werden sie alle haben
kürzlich den flüchtlingsgipfel
mitbekommen für mich ein Manifest der
ergebnislosigkeit und lange fest der
Tatenlosigkeit und so werden wir nicht
weitermachen können weil die Kurs den
Baden am Schluss die Landräte die
Oberbürgermeister und vor allem die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger aus muss
vielleicht auch mal dazu sagen gerade
die Bundespolizei mit denen ich einen
engen Kontakt habe haben seit einem Jahr
bundeszentrierter immer wieder darauf
hingewiesen dass die Situation eskaliert
dass die Zahlen im Vergleich zu den
vorherigen exorbitant wieder ansteigen
auch bei schlechter Witterung auch im
Winter und haben immer wieder darauf
gedrungen dass endlich etwas passieren
muss und diese Briefe und und brandmails
muss man fast sagen wo überhaupt nicht
beantwortet in der Öffentlichkeit äußert
sie sich komischerweise immer anders
zuletzt will sie jetzt plötzlich hohe
Zäune bauen aber in der Realität kommt
davon nichts an und dass ein
riesengroßes Problem gerade die
Bundespolizei sagt wir können an der
Grenze viel mehr tun ja können wir
gleich noch zu dem Thema Grenze das ist
auch ihr Thema Frau gaschkeller wollen
wir gleich noch mal ganz tief reingehen
ich möchte einmal beim Thema Fachkräfte
auch bleiben aber was glauben sie ist
Deutschland überhaupt noch das große
präferierte Ziel für qualifizierte
Fachkräfte ja andreas hat doch kürzlich
zwei wichtige Zahlen gesagt hat gemeint
dass im vorletzten Jahr eine Million
Menschen nach Deutschland kamen auf
verschiedenen deswegen übrigens
überwiegend nicht auf dem Weg Asyl und
das im selben Jahr aber auch 750.000
Menschen wieder gegangen sind und das
natürlich schon ein Problem wir IAB hat
kürzlich auch da gelegt dass wir ja etwa
400.000
Fachkräfte brauchen jedes Jahr und diese
Zahl erreichen wir jetzt gerade nicht
das zeigt schon dass mit der
Attraktivität irgendwas da hängt
irgendwie es fehlt ein bisschen bei der
Willkommenskultur Anerkennung von
Abschlüssen bei generell der Anerkennung
der Leistung
familiennachzugsfragen und so weiter und
so fort das heißt das sind die die die
die Fakten wo andere Länder tatsächlich
besser sind und deswegen auch das ich
meine das wird mich mal interessieren ja
skandinavischen Länder in vielen
Bereichen aber ich weil sie gemeint
haben viele Facetten und eine Facette
ist aber auch dass die Wirtschaft die
Herr Hoffmann gerade angesprochen hat
auch bei mir Händlerinnen und immer
wieder anruft und sagt okay wir brauchen
wir haben die Hälfte unserer Stellen in
Bayern die die schwer oder gar nicht
besetzt ist das würde mich interessieren
was sind das für stellen was brauchen
sie für Arbeitskräfte es gibt einen
weiten Bereich man kann es nicht nur
sagen nur Menschen in die eine
Ausbildung machen technisch nicht
technischen Berufen oder nur
Akademikerinnen also darf man auch nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen auch da eine
wichtige Botschaft brauchen wir beides
und ich glaube dass wir gerade die
Demographie als eine Berufe welche
Branchen wo fehlst da besonders in
vielen Branchen aber tatsächlich also
wir haben es gerade schon gehört beim im
Bereich der Pflege
obwohl da noch mal eigene Probleme im
Hintergrund stehen da gibt's auch viele
gute Arbeit gute Arbeitsbedingungen
Handwerk ähm und alle all unsere
Zukunftsbranchen die wir in der
Industrie auch haben muss gerade noch
mal dazwischen gleich mal sehen Sachen
Skandinavien er ist ein Vorbild Schweden
ist das unsicherste Land Europas weil
die genau diese Politik gemacht haben
die gerade ihre Ampelkoalition macht
nämlich Türen auf und gucken was
passiert Schweden ist gefährlich als
Albanien die haben die höchste Mordrate
in Europa die haben gerade Rolle
rückwärts gemacht und versuchen jetzt
mit Fahrzeugen genau dagegen zu steuern
ich glaube auch was jetzt auch gerade
wieder nicht so deutlich wird der Herr
von der CSU hat so ein bisschen versucht
wir haben doch drei Säulen und darüber
wird überhaupt nicht gesprochen es wird
immer vermischt wir haben einmal
Zuwanderung die wir brauchen aber von
qualifizierten Menschen die wir uns auch
aussuchen dürfen wen können wir brauchen
den brauchen wir hier wir wollen wir
hier dann haben wir das Asylverfahren da
gibt's Menschen und dann haben wir auch
illegale Migration und da haben wir
rechtsstaatliche Verfahren ich glaube da
sind wir uns ja alle einig wir haben ein
sehr funktionierenden Rechtsstaat und
wer in diesem Rechtsstaat einfach nach
mehreren Verfahren und endgültig gesagt
bekommt du darfst nicht bleiben der geht
aber nicht nach Hause und das ist unser
großes Problem wir vermischen drei
Säulen die wir haben und dass wir ein
Zuwanderungsgesetz seit Jahrzehnten
brauchen auch an ihre Schwesterpartei
und sie haben sie auch nie geschafft in
der großen Koalition nicht wir brauchen
das seit 20 Jahren dass wir Menschen
nach Deutschland holen die wir aber auch
hier brauchen wir glauben immer über das
wir machen die Türen auf gucken mal was
kommt und ob wir dann damit klarkommen
müssen wir sehen dazu kommt die Tür ist
einmal auf wer hier ist und das wissen
sie auch im Moment der bleibt auch hier
im letzten Jahr 36.000 Menschen sollten
nur abgeschoben werden obwohl 300.000
gehen müssen wie viel sind gegangen
13.000 weil die Menschen einfach
entweder bekommen sie es angekündigt sie
schmeißen ihre Ausweise Weg sie werden
dann kriegen ein Nervenzusammenbruch bei
der Abstimmung sie randalieren am
Flieger und dann passiert eben nicht und
das heißt wir bekommen immer mehr
Menschen ins Land und für die die wir
brauchen die wir wirklich dringend
brauchen da sind wir glaube ich uns ja
alle in der Runde einig die wir dringend
brauchen haben wir gar keinen Platz und
Möglichkeiten mehr weil die die wir gar
nicht hier haben wollen alles blockieren
und da tut einfach die Ampel überhaupt
nichts wie gesagt noch sagen ja von den
2015 gekommen eine Menschen sind die
Mehrheit inzwischen in Arbeit
25%
25% von den von denen im arbeitsfähigen
Alter 55 ja
das ist ja bei uns wir haben ja auch
keine Erwerbsquote in Deutschland von
100% im 55%, da sollten wir fanden ich
habe den Faktencheck hier dabei und den
kann ich ihn später auch noch mal zeigen
55%, aber denn und das ist viel höher
als in 90ern die aus dem ehemaligen
Jugoslawien hierher geflogen warum weil
wir Dinge ermöglicht haben weil wir ihn
ermöglicht haben in Arbeit zu kommen und
wir sehen uns auch bei den Ukrainerinnen
und Ukrainern da sehen wir es ja auch da
haben wir bei über einer Million wenn
die Zahl so stimmt also inzwischen ja
auch schon über 100000 Menschen in
kürzester Zeit vorbei Ukraine und woran
liegt das weil die natürlich in einem
anderen Rechtskreis die sind ja
ausgenommen die dürfen sofort die dürfen
mir sofort in einer Ausbildung und die
dürfen sofort an die Unterwäsche immer
das Argumentes deswegen ich werde oder
dafür aber die bringen es gibt
verschiedene aber denen sofort die
Möglichkeit zu geben dann wird die von
vielen vielen von den allermeisten noch
angenommen auf jeden Fall das ist ein
gefährlicher Anreiz weil sie am Schluss
schaffen sie ein Konjunkturpaket für
Schleuser wir wissen das aus vielen
Bereichen dass wenn dann klar ist wenn
z.B jemand nach Deutschland kommt oder
kann sofort arbeiten dann wissen die
auch dass das sofort die Schleuser
Dienste bezahlen kann
frau Gaschke ist hier bei uns und sie
fordern Frau Gaschke eine konkrete
Steuerung ein neues Asylgesetz das ist
ihre Frage ja vor allen Dingen ich
fordere das gar nicht so sehr das sind
ja alles aus alles aus wir sind ja alle
hilflos letzten Endes wir wissen der
UNHCR berechnet also bis bis 2050 mit
weltweit 200 Millionen Flüchtlingen aus
aus Klima Gründen aus Kriegsgründen aus
armutsgründen so irgendwo zwischen einer
Millionen guten Millionen die wir im
Jahr schaffen und 200 Millionen auf der
Welt die wir ganz bestimmt in
Deutschland nicht schaffen können liegt
ja die Wahrheit und wir kriegen das im
Moment einfach sehr sehr schlecht
sortiert in der Tat also das Asylrecht
ist überhaupt kein vernünftiges
Einwanderungsrecht für Arbeitskräfte das
funktioniert nicht die Probleme in der
Praxis liegen natürlich auch daran dass
wir zum Teil die Leute auch wenn Sie
hier strafbar sind und raus müssen nicht
zurückgeschoben kriegen weil die
jackensländer nicht kooperieren insofern
ist natürlich alles was danach mühsamer
Diplomatie und Politik klingt dass man
irgendwie versucht den Leuten zu einigen
und zu sagen wir machen also
bewerbungszentren schon in euren Ländern
und wir versuchen das vorher zu klären
und dafür es gibt also eine legale gute
Chance nach Deutschland zu kommen dafür
nehmt ihr bei eure Verbrecher auch bitte
zurück das ist alles richtig aber das
ist alles wenig das sind kleine Zahlen
und das Problem ist einfach die
Bevölkerung trägt es langsam nicht mehr
mit und auch dazu gibt es eben geben um
Fragezeichen auch aus der vergangenen
Woche von Alsbach die das immer
liebevoll also im Detail sich angucken
also 60 bis 60 % im ganz Deutschland in
Ostdeutschland sogar 70 % sagen wir
können nicht mehr Flüchtlinge aufnehmen
50% wollen das Asylrecht geändert haben
und 85 % sagen jetzt mach doch endlich
mal ein Einwanderungsgesetz das
irgendwie ein klares Signal setzt solche
Leute wollen wir hier haben
also in drei schnellen punkten wenn sie
Chefin werden was müsste in diesem
Gesetz stehen lassen keine Ahnung das
kann ich ihn wirklich nicht sagen es ist
unheimlich komplex und schwierig wir
sehen ja auch dass wir das vielleicht
der Pferdes aber auch noch mal gesagt
also wir haben natürlich im eigenen
Umgang mit ausländischen Arbeitskräften
oder migrantischen Arbeitskräften noch
Luft nach oben also es gibt schon auch
gut qualifizierte Leute die gerne hier
arbeiten wollen und unglaublich
schikaniert werden von den Behörden ich
meine Vermutung auch so aus einer
gewissen Kenntnis der Praxis ist weil es
einfacher ist ordentliche Leute die sich
gut anpassen und was wollen noch ein
paar bürokratische Schwierigkeiten zu
machen als die richtig harten Fälle mal
zu verarzten also dazu gibt es leider
eine Neigung in in Bürokratien und das
ist glaube ich ein Teil unseres Problems
und wir haben ja Fachkräftemangel also
die die nicht also uns fehlen ja die
Leute und wir wissen es seit Jahren sind
heute so groß wie
auf europäischer Ebene haben wir dieses
Thema ja schon angeschnitten gehabt da
hast du auch angesprochen wir brauchen
da eine strengere Grenzsicherung absolut
die Bundespolizei Predigt das auch wie
gesagt seit gut einem Jahr frau Kaiser
aber sie will das einfach nicht hören
und dann ist immer die Rede davon wir
können unsere Grenzen nicht zu machen
die Außengrenzen werden aber auch nicht
vernünftig geschützt teilweise sind
andere Länder muss man sagen innerhalb
Europas auch sehr unfair die dann
einfach sagen die deutschen schaffen die
Anreize dann geht doch auch durch die
wollt doch gar nicht zu uns gar nicht
sehen das momentan auch mit der Schweiz
ganz extrem
gesetzt durchleucht hier aussteigen
diese Richtung bitte gehen das ist aber
dadurch natürlich entstanden weil wir
Deutschen dieses Gefühl vermitteln
während wir nehmen alle auf und deswegen
kann ich das unterschreiben dass er
Asylgesetz zu verschärfen denn wer
einmal bei uns ist das ist momentan
einfach vergeben geht nicht mehr denn
man muss auch noch mal eins sagen auch
die Justiz spielt eine sehr eigenartige
Rolle Verwaltungsgerichte Leben zum
Beispiel Rückführung nur nach dem Dublin
Abkommen nach Italien Griechenland
momentan ab weil dort die Unterbringung
und medizinische Versorgung nicht so gut
ist wie bei uns also muss ich mir
vorstellen kann demnächst auch jeder
Grieche und Italiener also überantragen
weil es ihm da schlechter geht als bei
uns ich meine das hat überhaupt gar
keine Logik mehr dann sind alle Abkommen
wie du den und ähnliche Dinge absurd
weil sie sie funktionieren hinten und
vorne nicht mehr und wenn wir 300.000
Menschen hier haben die einfach nicht
zurückgehen und ich habe ja kürzlich
erst beschrieben es gibt wirklich die
werden aufgegriffen es steht drin im
Computer sofort ausreisepflichtig dann
wird versucht eine Ermittlungsrichter zu
sein der sagt ich habe keine Haftplätze
hier in Berlin sind ja geschlossen der
Flughafen das macht zu mit dem
abschiebebereich es gibt ja gar keine
Plätze wo Faeser schließt die letzten
sogar noch und dann sagt man es gibt
keine Plätze wir können den nicht
abschieben da kriegt er einen Zettel in
die Hand melde dich bitte am Montag bei
deinem Ausländeramt sozusagen zur
Abschiebung an ja dass der da Montag
nicht aufläuft wissen wir alle das heißt
wir haben kein funktionierendes
Rechtssystem mehr und da ist ein
riesengroßes Problem weil sagt Volker
Gaschke zurecht die Menschen merken das
und da kippt irgendwann die Stimmung und
das kann in sozialen Unfrieden ändern
indem keiner will
komplexes Thema wir haben leider heute
müssen wir pünktlich aufhören wir sehen
aber das ist ein hochkomplexes Thema und
ich würde sie alle gerne einladen dass
wir dieses Thema gemeinsam auch noch mal
weiter besprechen denn man sieht in
diesem Thema ist sehr sehr viel drin
vielen herzlichen Dank daher an meine
Gäste und vielen herzlichen Dank an sie
an die Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer bis
ganz bald bei 8:15 Uhr
[Musik]